hey guys welcome Ike the new rockstars
my name is Sam basher and I love
superheroes not sure if that is clear by
this time of all the numerous you know
flash breakdowns that I've done in the
trailer Easter egg hunts but I just want
to make it clear I want to come out and
say that I love superheroes I love them
I love everything about them I love
their stories I love their costumes I
love how they team up I love their
powers I love everything and what I love
most though is when I'll get to play
together you know I mean be sure it's
good when they're written well and the
stories are compelling but you know it's
how cool is it when Wolverine invite me
I get to punch each other it's just so
cool and that's why the news of the
possibility of Disney buying out most of
the assets from 20th Century Fox makes
fans so excited this is signaling to us
that our Marvel family will finally be
back together - all those weird Sony
movies about spider-man venom and black
and silver I don't know what they're
doing over there I just really hope they
stop it's just silly
anyway the big thing here is that our
family is finally back together the MCU
will have another Home Coming the
estranged x-men side of the family will
be back they're gonna have a big party I
hope I'm invited and this means we'll
finally get some of our fan favorite
team ups in the comics on the big screen
finally imagine the possibilities no
really like give it a go because I did
and now I'm gonna share some of my
awesome potential what-ifs with you hold
they just made me so excited let's kick
it off with the one showdown that I've
been dying for Hulk vs. Wolverine
Wolverine was introduced in the
Incredible Hulk issue 180 back in 1974
and it's been a never-ending fan debate
of just exactly which of these years
would be the victor in a one-on-one
fight now who would play Wolverine in
this new era that's hard to say Hugh
Jackman seems pretty much done with the
role understandably so we could get a
new beat maybe who do you think could
possibly win in this fight by the way
ultimate healing ability versus
unstoppable strength Duke it out in the
comments down below I think the whole
could win one really cool thing we could
see is the exploration of scarlet
witch's character with the knowledge
that her real father is Magneto
depending on which comic you're reading
and also let's not focus on the current
status of Scarlet Witch family situation
in the MCU because it's a little
depressing but this could lead to some
pretty epic storylines in the x-men
films we've mainly focused on Magneto's
troubled past and more extremist
viewpoints but we haven't had too much
of magneto the teacher imagine magneto
having to talk down Scarlet Witch when
she goes full chaos magic and starts
warping
oh pretty cool also I wouldn't mind if
the writers found a way to work Evan
Peters Quicksilver into the MCU not to
get into fan debate about which
Quicksilver is better MCU or the x-men
but I personally prefer Peter from the X
franchise and I'd love to see that
specific speedster taking on Thanos he's
already thought one purplish person
before you know purple-ish speaking of
magneto imagine him taking on the
Avengers for just a second like an
actual super-powered villain but the
team needs to take on what do we want
magneto ripping apart Tony Stark's suits
maybe even crushing cap shield what
would happen if you know vision and
magneto duked it out see it's getting
pretty exciting the more you think about
it and of course we'd have our Avengers
become more resourceful and then up
their game and eventually they'd beat
magneto cause of course but sorry I'm
getting ahead of myself here we'll be
back to villains and a little bit but
back to the hero team-ups actually this
does bring up an interesting point
though imagine the Avengers having to
deal with the introduction of
super-powered beings on earth
ignoring the in humans because Marvel
the company seems to be doing that I
watched all of the Inhumans TV show
because I hate myself I'd say they look
to recruit a few of these mutants as
fast as possible personally when my
favorite runs of the Avengers had beast
on the team and I personally loved
seeing him with those teammates is
really exciting for me but if they
wanted to pick a more popular hero I'd
say maybe like Katie pride because she
has been a part of the Avengers and the
guardians of the galaxy before maybe
even rogue because she's currently
leading an Avengers team in the comics
Wolverine because he's part of one of my
favorite runs of the New Avengers
written by Brian Michael Bendis or even
possibly working with Professor X maybe
Professor X wouldn't be an asset in the
field but he could be a coordinator and
he used telepathy to you know link the
team up speaking of teams by the way I
think this could be an opening for the
Fantastic Four to get another shot at
the big screen and it could finally work
maybe sure the first Fantastic Four
outing
wasn't a total failure the sequel didn't
do great but Josh Trank's fantastic
really left a bad taste in fans mouths I
think that the MCU could really nail
these characters whether it be on the
big screen or in the small screen with a
Fantastic Four TV show possibly this
team is right in Marvel's wheelhouse and
with that we could finally get the thing
versus the Hulk fight that would be just
epic or flip it and you can get the
thing and Thor teaming up and going on
intergalactic adventures I know in Thor
Ragnarok you got the Hulk and Thor
teaming up but
the original team up buddy-cop story the
ER love was the thing in Thor
they were rock divers a hammer guy also
in case you didn't see it Chris Evans
tweeted about the Human Torch and cat
meeting and how weird it would be but if
he was Michael B Jordans Human Torch
that could be actually a little bit
exciting but if Marvel just wanted to go
as weird as possible for my benefit I'd
love to see Chris Evans play both roles
why I don't know because of a child on
the inside that's all I want
come on let's talk tantrum in the
theater also worth bringing up the
Fantastic Four has switched up its
roster a few times in the past sometimes
to include she-hulk spider-man and Ghost
Rider Scott Lang's ant-man the Inhumans
the list goes on and on
so if Marvel wanted to stray away from
the Avenger films after phase four the
Fantastic Four could be their new baby
to work with so think about it but back
to the other awesome team EPS that would
be awesome to see on the big screen here
are the two that I'm personally most
excited for one spider-man and Deadpool
doesn't have to be a versus movie Don of
whatever but maybe just a team-up film I
know what you're thinking our current
Spider Man is so young and innocent and
him interacting with Deadpool a killer
could just ruin the boy but right now
their team-up comic is one of the most
delightful series each month that I get
to pick up and I love the idea a
Deadpool being a huge fan of spider-man
and wanting to impress them so they work
together
would that work in a movie form I don't
know but it wouldn't hurt to try
sometimes it does hurt to try but hey
staying positive no the one team-up that
I want to see most of all is Black
Panther and storm I know the current
status of storm in the movies is kind of
weird she's younger but it's in the 90s
so maybe present day should be older I
don't know how they do it in the MCU but
if the x-men were introduced in the MCU
films I would love to see a relationship
with storm and Black Panther because I
love the relationship in the comics I
know every studio loves a will they or
won't they storyline between their
characters and I don't think a lot of
people really bought the whole Hulk and
Black Widow relationship I'll be honest
I didn't so these two could be your next
big it couple come on you love that fan
fiction don't you also just imagine the
fight scenes you see black panther
stalking some like terrorists or drug
dealers in the jungle he's climbing
through the trees and crash you see a
lightning strike overhead and you pan up
and you see storm just floating there
wide-eyed and everything together they
just take out the bad guys and bam
they're making out who's it hot in here
is it just me but enough about those
boring heroes let's talk about the
villains Fox has been sitting on
Marvel's best baddies for a while now
and
now we're gonna see them take on the
Avengers hopefully you guys don't know
I'm talking about Magneto dr. doom even
Galactus imagine that people the
Avengers versus another purple giant he
better not be some cloud floating around
in space I'll tell you that he better be
just some giant dude with boots on and a
fork on his head but I'll get that for
who I'm not gonna be happy let me know
in the comments if you'd be upset if you
didn't have that fork on his head also
that would mean that we'd have the
Silver Surfer in the MCU and that would
mean we would get one on my favorite
Marvel characters and that makes me
pretty happy I know it's selfish but I
don't care and just think about this
you'd finally get a team of villains or
as a team a heroes which DC kind of tees
with the Legion of Doom but maybe Marvel
could get to it first
who knows maybe but back to the villains
for a second imagine seeing our team of
Avengers going to Latveria and having to
take on doom the current Avengers
wouldn't do so well it'd be very scary
or even imagine doom teaming up with
Doctor Strange in his own solo movie to
go to hell to save dooms mother that's a
very popular story for doom or even
imagine seeing doom go through a
Redemption arc and becoming the infamous
Iron Man the current character he is in
the comics I wouldn't need that but
these are just possibilities hell we
could even get Namor since his ownership
is all over the place I'm not really
sure if that's possible but imagine he
could actually be in the MCU he is part
mutant so makes sense he's part of this
buy up but he might actually also be
owned by Universal so who knows what we
do know is that this would give us some
classic Namor versus Avengers storylines
and we'd see a whole new side of the MCU
Atlantis which is another name for this
underwater world and it would
differentiate the MCU from DC and
Atlantis and Aquaman however they
introduced him he would have ties to
both the x-men and The Avengers being
that he's also a mutant and we would
have one of Marvel's most complicated
characters hey sometimes a hero
sometimes the vicious killer could be a
very interesting to see the king of
Atlantis go up against the king of
Wakanda King versus King haven't seen
that yet in the MCU and now back to
magneto for just a second to talk about
the mutant cause imagine having to deal
with Magneto on a grander scale not just
mutants trying to stop him but the whole
world think of his ideology being
explored on a larger scale or even a
smaller scale like possibly a Netflix
series so far the Netflix series have
really handled more difficult topics
very well so imagine them having to deal
with x-men or mutant racism
in a 13-episode series much like Luke
Cage or Jessica Jones something like
this in a TV show or even a movie could
lead to one of my favorite comic book
events actually coming to the big screen
House of M a world where mutants are
king magneto and his family are the top
dogs and meetin's feel at home finally
they're finally welcomed and the
Avengers have to find a way to turn
everything back because it's not perfect
it's not it's not totally perfect but
hey if that story's not your cup of tea
imagine all the other major Marvel
events that could play out on the big
screen with the x-men and a Fantastic
Four versus the rest of the MCU we could
have either version of Secret Wars one
being on battle world where all the
characters have to fight each other or a
world made up of different pieces of the
multiverse that's led by God Doom yes
God doom it's very scary maybe even
Secret Invasion you could have the
scrolls shape-shifting and replacing key
heroes in the MCU and then the x-men and
the Avengers have a team up in space oh
there are so many storytelling
possibilities with this merger and I
just can't wait what are we definitely
getting in some form or another Avengers
vs. x-men probably I mean we have Thor
versus Iron Man for some reason the
first Avengers movie I mean they didn't
have to fight they kind of just talked
about it let's be real but that's it
guys here's just some quick bonuses that
I just you know came to my head number
one we'd finally have a full Marvel
Universe not just heroes and all the
people on earth but also the aliens as
well we wouldn't just get some weird
hybrids of them or reconfiguring
storylines so that we don't step on the
toes of other Studios we'd actually have
a full roster of aliens out in the
Marvel Universe the guardians of the
galaxy would have a whole new set of
foes to go up against to be very
exciting too if Sony decided to stop
being weird about their venom solo movie
and the rest of their weird spider-man
solo movies and just wrap them up into
the MCU we could finally get venom
versus the x-men and Avengers and then
we could possibly get venom versions of
our favorite heroes and I just eat that
up I love that kind of stuff we're
getting a spider verse animated movie
why not a venom verse movie it's an idea
and three the final one Deadpool vs.
Thanos they're both in love with mr.
death and I would love to see Santos
fight someone they just couldn't die
just can't no matter what just can't
these always heals you can't die but
anyways guys that's it from me I hope
you enjoyed this video be sure to let me
know in the comments down below or on
twitter at san basher which of these
team ups would be your face
or maybe some that I may have missed
that you'd like to see but before you do
that make sure you like this video share
with your friends and subscribe for more
breakdowns we've got a bunch of last
Jedi stuff coming your way and make sure
you check out neat to know it's a show
that I'm on we talk about nerdy stuff
it's pretty fun but again guys I'm Sam
basher I hope you enjoyed and I'll see
you guys next time bye bye